je l'ai vu en décembre on s'appelle
régulièrement on prend des vers ensemble
car on tempend vers le même but voilà ce
qu'aurait déclaré à mediaapart le
porte-parole de la campagne de Marine Le
Pen Paul Marie couteau à propos de
Guillaume Peltier ce but commun il s'en
explique dans l'article paru ce mercredi
ce serait travailler à la recomposition
de la droite une alliance fnump qui
pourrait se faire selon lui après
l'échec de Nicolas Sarkozi une
collaboration que le principal
intéressit dément je n'ai aucun aucune
rencontre avec lui depuis depuis 2007 et
que tout ça est est faux et archifux et
que ce qui est extrêmement clair et je
peux vous le répéter avec beaucoup de de
sérénité c'est qu'il n'est pas
envisageable une seule seconde que la
majorité
présidentielle nous des acccords avec
qui que ce soit Guillaume Peltier nommé
officiellement ce mercredi secrétaire
national de l'UMP en charge des enquêtes
d'opinion et des sondage souligne la
coïncidence dans le calendrier entre
lapparution de cet article et sa
nomination tion dès qu'on a une
promotion dans notre pays beaucoup
d'aigris et de et de jaloux s'amusent et
ça concerne aussi bien d'ailleurs des
responsables de la droite et de la
gauche je s'amuse à à colporter des des
calomnies des médisances ça relève de la
de la diffamation selon Paul Marie
couteau celui qui fut secrétaire général
du Mouvement pour la France ne serait
aujourd'hui pas allergique à Marine Le
Pen Guillaume Peltier a beau évoqué
l'extrême droite comme une erreur de
jeunesse dans son propre camp on s de
voir son engagement au côté de la
majorité présidentielle constamment
remise en cause si Monsieur couteau a
menti et bien il faut le dire si
Madame la journaliste de mdiap a mal
fait son travail il faut le dire mais
les éléments qui sont apportés me semble
jeter quand même le doute sur la loyauté
de Monsieur ptier vis-à-vis de Monsieur
Sarkozi le secrétaire général adjoint de
l'UMP Hervé Novelli n'a quant à lui pas
souhaité réagir estimant que c'était de
la fabulation une polémique dont on se
serait sans doute bien passé dans les
rangs de la droite à 3 mois des
élections présidentielles